Hello listeners. I'm Nancy Updike. If you heard last week's show you know I'm filling in for Ira Glass. He's out reporting a great story for you. He will be back next week. But while he's gone, I thought maybe we could have movie night.
听众朋友们好。我是南希·厄普代克。如果你听了上周的节目，就知道我是代艾拉·格拉斯主持的。他去为各位报道一个精彩的故事了。他下周会回来。在他离开期间，我想我们或许可以举办个电影之夜。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
Clearly this isn't a movie that was made in the recent past. But it was a blockbuster and an Oscar winner. It was huge. It's called, The Best Years of Our Lives , and it's a war movie, really a post-war movie. Three men are coming back from a war, World War II, to the same town they all lived in before the war. And the movie is about their hard transition back into civilian life. It's black and white, full of words like swell, but while I was watching it I kept thinking, "This could be about today."
很明显，这不是一部近期拍摄的电影。但它曾是一部大片，也获得过奥斯卡奖。它非常受欢迎。电影名字叫《黄金时代》，是一部战争题材电影，准确说是战后题材。三名男子从第二次世界大战的战场回到他们战前居住的同一个城镇。电影讲述了他们回归平民生活时所面临的艰难转变。这是部黑白片，满是“好极了”之类的老式用语，但在观看时，我一直想：“这拍的不就是今天吗？”
In the beginning of the movie the three men are on a military plane on their way home. And as they get closer, instead of getting excited they get quiet and edgy. Fred, the young airman who's got some swagger asks the older guy, Al--
电影开头，三名男子正坐在一架军用飞机上回家。随着离家越来越近，他们没有变得兴奋，反而变得沉默且焦躁。弗雷德，那个有些狂妄自大的年轻飞行员，问年纪稍长的艾尔——
Remember what it felt like when you went overseas?
还记得你去海外时是什么感觉吗？
As well as I remember my own name.
就像记得自己的名字一样清楚。
I feel the same way now, only more so.
我现在感觉也一样，甚至更强烈。
I know what you mean. Just nervous out of the service, I guess. The thing that scares me most is that everybody's going to try to rehabilitate me.
我明白你的意思。我想，刚退伍都会这样紧张吧。我最害怕的是，每个人都想对我进行“改造”。
That's Al, the older one, worrying about people rehabilitating him. It's surprising when says it. He's the one who seems least visibly affected by the war, not a candidate for any kind of rehabilitation or even help. Al just seems like a gentle, somewhat stiff family man who's been married for 20 years and will be married for another 20 years.
那是艾尔，年纪较大的那个，他担心人们会“改造”他。当他说出这话时真让人惊讶。他看起来是受战争影响最不明显的一个，完全不需要任何改造或帮助。艾尔看起来只是个温和、有些古板的居家男人，已经结婚20年，还会再过20年这样的日子。
But on the first night back it's obvious he's not OK. He's tense. He can barely sit still. He insists on taking his wife and daughter out on the town and proceeds to get more drunk than I've seen someone his age get in a movie in a long time. He sloshes around the dance floor with his wife, Milly, played by Myrna Loy. And at one point he starts into a little joke that his wife gamely plays along with.
但在回家的第一晚，很明显他状态不对。他很紧张。几乎坐不住。他坚持带妻子和女儿去镇上，结果喝得烂醉，那是我在电影里见过同龄人中喝得最凶的一次。他拖着妻子米莉（由玛娜·洛伊饰演）在舞池里摇晃。有那么一刻，他开始讲个小笑话，而他的妻子也很配合地演了下去。
You're a bewitching little creature. In a way you remind me of my wife.
你真是个迷人的小妖精。从某种程度上看，你让我想起了我妻子。
But you never told me you're married.
可你从没告诉过我你结婚了。
Oh yeah. I've got a little woman, two kiddies, back there in the States.
噢，是的。我在国内有个小女人，还有两个孩子。
But let's not think of them now.
但咱们现在别想他们了。
Oh, you're so right. This night belongs only to us.
噢，你说得太对了。今晚只属于我们。
I found this one of the most poignant moments in the film, even with Al's drunkenness. These are two people trying to make light of something huge, the fear of being strangers after so long apart. Do you still know me? Am I still me? From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. Today on the show, a question. Will they know me back home? Stay with us.
我觉得这是片中最感人的时刻之一，即便艾尔当时喝醉了。这是两个人试图淡化一件大事——害怕在分别这么久之后变得形同陌路。你还了解我吗？我还是从前的我吗？来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》，由公共广播国际公司发行。今天的节目有个问题：回到家乡，他们还能认出我吗？请继续收听。
We're going to have just two stories on the show today. Both are about men and women living through war and trying to figure out how to live their lives outside of war. These are stories from the most recent, officially combat ended war the US has fought, the Iraq War. And a word about how we chose these stories. We've been reading about the wars-- Afghanistan, Iraq-- from the beginning, just like you probably have. And we've forgotten a lot of what we've read, like you probably have. These are stories we couldn't forget.
今天的节目只有两个故事。两个故事都关于在战争中生存的男女，以及他们试图弄清如何在战后生活。这些故事来自美国参与的最近一场正式结束战斗的战争——伊拉克战争。关于我们如何选择这些故事，提一句：像你们大多数人一样，我们从一开始就一直阅读有关阿富汗和伊拉克战争的报道。我们也像你们一样，忘记了很多读过的内容。但这些故事是我们无法忘记的。
The first one is from a stupendously well-reported book by journalist David Finkel called The Good Soldiers. He followed one group of soldiers for 15 months, at war and at home. Lots of reporters have done something like this. But he observes and describes these soldiers' "corner of the war," as he puts it, with such precision and without comment. Reading it, you don't analyze the war, you don't ponder it. You feel it.
第一个故事摘自记者大卫·芬克尔那本报道极其详尽的著作《好兵》。他在15个月里跟踪记录了一群士兵，无论是在战场还是在家里。有很多记者做过类似的事，但他以极高的精确度观察并描述了这些士兵“战争的一隅”，且不做任何评注。读这本书时，你不会去分析战争，也不会去深思它。你会感同身受。
One chapter stood out, the one where the soldiers go home on leave for 18 days, and their wives and families talk about waiting for them. And with David's permission we're doing something unusual with this chapter to put it on the air. In the book, the individual voices of the soldiers and their wives come through so clearly you hear them in your head. We wanted to recreate that, so we worked with David to turn the chapter into a series of monologues, that each could be read by separate person, the same way you hear them in your head while you're reading. So these are actors reading, not the soldiers. But what they're reading is what the soldiers and their wives told David and what he saw.
其中一章非常突出，讲的是士兵们回家休假18天，以及他们的妻子和家人谈论等待他们的感受。经大卫许可，我们对这一章做了些不同寻常的处理以便在广播中播出。在书中，士兵及其妻子的个人心声非常清晰，读的时候仿佛能在脑海中听到他们的声音。我们想重现这一点，于是和大卫合作，将这一章改编成一系列独白，每一段由不同的人朗读，就像你阅读时在脑海中听到的那样。所以这些朗读者是演员，而非士兵本人。但他们朗读的内容正是士兵及其妻子告诉大卫的，以及大卫亲眼所见的。
Briefly, here's what the soldiers were living through before they went on leave. David embedded with an army battalion known as the 216, from Fort Riley, Kansas, during one of the most difficult periods of the Iraq War. The surge, when the US sent small groups of soldiers and Marines out from the big, well-protected bases they'd been living in into dangerous neighborhoods all over Baghdad, where they would live for weeks at a time. Before the surge worked, it was terrifying. Every day, sniper attacks and IEDs that got more sophisticated and more lethal over time. IEDs were on every road the 216 drove for a year. They were triggered by remote control-- in other words, people watching them. And there was no consistent pattern to where and when they exploded. It could, and did, happen any time.
简而言之，这就是士兵们在休假前所经历的生活。大卫深入驻扎在堪萨斯州赖利堡的第216陆军营，记录了伊拉克战争中最困难的一段时期——“增兵期”。当时美国将小型士兵和海军陆战队分队从防御严密的大型基地派往巴格达各地危险的街区，他们要在那里一住就是几周。在增兵取得成效之前，那段日子极其恐怖。每一天都有狙击手袭击和简易爆炸装置（IED），这些装置随时间推移变得越来越复杂、致命。216营过去一年行驶的每条路上都有IED。它们是远程控制引爆的——换句话说，有人在盯着看。而且爆炸地点和时间毫无规律可言。随时可能发生，也确实随时都在发生。
The soldiers started going home on leave in the middle of that year, the fall of 2007. The average age in the unit was 19. Heads up, these are young soldiers on leave. There's some swearing. We beep it. There's also a description of going to a strip club. Here's the chapter.
2007年秋天，那一年中期，士兵们开始轮流回家休假。部队平均年龄是19岁。注意，这些是在休假的年轻士兵。里面有一些脏话，我们进行了消音处理。还有一段关于去脱衣舞俱乐部的描述。下面是这一章的内容。
The first thing I did was take $1,500 and take my two brothers to the mall. No. The first thing I did was take off my uniform in the airport parking lot, put on shorts and a T-shirt that my brothers had brought me, and then go to the mall.
我做的第一件事就是拿出1500美元，带我两个兄弟去商场。不，我做的第一件事是在机场停车场脱掉军装，换上兄弟带给我的短裤和T恤，然后去商场。
For three hours we bought whatever we wanted, sale or no sale, as if money didn't matter. And what I bought was new pants, a new shirt, and new athletic shoes. All in white. Pure white because I wanted to feel clean.
我们疯狂购物了三个小时，不管打不打折，钱根本不是问题。我买了新裤子、新衬衫和新运动鞋。全是白色的。纯白，因为我想让自己感觉干净点。
From there I went home to see the rest of my family. And that's where the questions began. "What do you do," they asked. "Well, we go out," I said. I wasn't sure how to describe it, so I showed them pictures instead. That's Harrelson's Humvee on fire. That's Craig's Humvee right after he died. Those are some kids in Kamalaya.
之后我回家见家里其他人。接着，问题就开始了。“你们在那儿做什么？”他们问。“哦，我们就出去巡逻，”我说。我不确定该怎么形容，于是给他们看照片。那是哈雷尔森的悍马车着火的样子。那是克雷格死后刚拍的悍马车。那些是卡马拉亚的孩子们。
My grandma started crying. She knew about the deaths. But this was seeing how people lived, the [BLEEP] trenches and stuff. I showed her a picture of a Humvee stuck in a [BLEEP] trench and she asked if that was mud, and I tried to explain it was [BLEEP] and that those lakes on the side were [BLEEP] [BLEEP] and she didn't want to see any more. She got up and went in the other room, and she got busy ordering me my favorite dinner, which is chicken parmesan.
我奶奶开始哭。她知道有人阵亡。但那是亲眼看到人们的生活方式，看到那些该死的战壕之类的东西。我给她看一张悍马车陷进该死战壕的照片，她问那是不是泥巴，我试图解释那是屎，边上的那些湖是该死的粪坑，她不想再看了。她起身去了另一个房间，开始忙着给我做我最爱吃的晚餐——鸡肉帕尔马干酪。
My first day went from there. I ate some marvelous chicken parmesan, bought my first legal six-pack of beer. Then I went with my brothers and some friends to the Yankee Bar and Grill for the Friday night wet T-shirt contest. I drank beer. I drank tequila. I drank Crown Royal. I drank another beer. I drank a flaming Dr Pepper. I drank something else. I don't even know what the [BLEEP] it was, but they put something on fire and dropped it in a beer.
第一天就这样过去了。我吃了美味的鸡肉帕尔马干酪，买了人生中第一打合法的啤酒。然后我和兄弟还有几个朋友去了洋基酒吧烧烤店，参加周五晚上的湿T恤大赛。我喝啤酒，喝龙舌兰，喝皇冠威士忌。又喝了一杯啤酒。喝了一杯燃烧的“怪医博士”。我还喝了别的。我甚至不知道那他妈是什么，但他们把什么东西点着火丢进了啤酒里。
I danced with a girl, told her I was home from Iraq. Danced with another girl, told her I was home from Iraq. I was wearing my new white shirt and white pants and white shoes, and I was feeling pretty good about things. And, yes, I was drunk. Totally drunk. But not so drunk I didn't hear people calling out my name and telling me to get on stage.
我和一个女孩跳舞，告诉她我是从伊拉克回来的。又和另一个女孩跳舞，告诉她我是从伊拉克回来的。我穿着我的新白衬衫、白裤子和白鞋，感觉棒极了。当然，我喝醉了。彻底喝醉了。但还没醉到听不见人们喊我的名字，让我上台。
So my brother and I went up there and I sat in one chair and my brother sat in another chair, back to back. And there was a stripper pole in between us. And six girls in T-shirts came on stage and started dancing around us in a circle. And I yell over to my brother, "Dude, there's no [BLEEP] way."
于是我和兄弟走上去，我坐在一把椅子上，他坐在另一把上，背靠背。中间有一根脱衣舞杆。六个穿T恤的女孩上台，围着我们跳起舞来。我朝兄弟大喊：“伙计，这他妈简直不敢相信。”
And then there's water hoses, and the girls are soaked from head to toe and dancing through puddles, and taking off their T-shirts. And then one of the girls is stepping onto my new white shoes and leaning toward me and pushing her chest toward my face. And then she's climbing onto my lap and standing on my thighs with her wet dirty feet to get onto the strippers' pole, And she's trying to step onto my shoulders. And me, all I can think about was my new white shoes, my new white pants, my new white shirt.
接着还有水管喷水，女孩们全身湿透，在水坑里跳舞，脱掉T恤。其中一个女孩踩在我崭新的白鞋上，向我倾身，把胸部凑到我脸边。然后她爬上我的大腿，用湿漉漉、脏兮兮的脚站在我大腿上，好抓到脱衣舞杆。她还试图踩上我的肩膀。而我，满脑子想的都是我的白鞋、白裤子、白衬衫。
But then I remembered it didn't really matter. I had more money. I could buy more clothes tomorrow. So I started laughing and cheering, and then someone yelled in the microphone, "Welcome back from Iraq!" And then a woman was saying, "I'll give you a ride home tonight." And then we were parked in front of my house, kissing. And then I passed out on her chest, drunk. Done. She woke me up, "Maybe we should do this another night?" "Yeah." I went inside, passed out again, and dreamed of an explosion.
但随后我想起，这真的无所谓。我有钱。明天可以买更多的衣服。于是我开始大笑、欢呼，接着有人在麦克风里喊：“欢迎从伊拉克归来！”后来一个女人说：“今晚我送你回家。”我们把车停在我家门前接吻。然后我就醉倒在她怀里了。完了。她叫醒我：“也许我们改天再来？”“好的。”我进屋，又昏睡过去，梦见了爆炸。
"Dude, what's wrong?" my brother said as he sat up, wide-eyed. I passed out again and then the phone began ringing. "They're trying to call me. They're trying to call me," I began screaming. I had a cigarette and passed out again. Then it was morning and my grandmother was the one leaning towards me saying, "Here's some orange juice." 17 days to go.
“伙计，你怎么了？”兄弟坐起来，瞪大眼睛问。我又昏睡过去，接着电话响了。“他们在叫我，他们在叫我，”我开始尖叫。抽了根烟，又昏睡过去。到了早上，是我奶奶俯身对我说：“喝点橙汁吧。”还有17天。
Nine months along. Where's home now? Is it back there where my wife Stephanie recorded this video of my three kids on my birthday? Or is it here, where I watch it?
已经九个月了。家现在在哪里？是在那个我妻子斯蒂芬妮录下孩子们生日视频的地方吗？还是在这里，我看着视频的地方？
[CHILDREN SINGING "HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU"]
[孩子们唱着“祝你生日快乐”]
Is home the place where the kids grow so steadily that it's invisible? Or here, where I notice it in increments, like a distant relative?
家是不是孩子们长得太快以至于察觉不到的地方？还是这里，我像远房亲戚一样一点点地注意到他们的成长？
Dear son, the weather this weekend has been glorious. The leaves are all turning color, no wind, the temperature's in the upper 60s, low 70s. Are there any other signs of fall in Iraq except the more reasonable temperatures? Your loving mom and dad.
亲爱的儿子，这个周末天气棒极了。叶子全变色了，没有风，气温在60多到70华氏度之间（约15-22摄氏度）。伊拉克除了气温比较合理，还有其他秋天的迹象吗？爱你的爸妈。
Dear mom and dad, it's still 100 degrees here. The leaves are not turning color. Love, Ralph.
亲爱的爸妈，这儿还是100华氏度（约38摄氏度）。叶子没变色。爱你的，拉尔夫。
Hi, love, I love you. Well, today I've spent in vacation research craziness. I found flights to Florida and hotel and resort packages for January. Would you rather a hotel or a condo? Meals included, or not? Disney or Universal? Thoughts?
嗨，亲爱的，我爱你。嗯，今天我忙于度假调研，简直疯了。我查到了去佛罗里达的航班，还有一月份的酒店和度假套餐。你想要酒店还是公寓？包餐吗？去迪士尼还是环球影城？有什么想法？
Stephanie Corey, As long as I get to spend all the time with you and the kids we can do it in a bungalow upside-down for all I care. Do need a heated pool. Your choice on all. Hugs, Ralph Wester.
斯蒂芬妮·科里，只要能和你还有孩子们在一起，就算住倒过来的平房我也无所谓。只是需要个加热泳池。都听你的。拥抱你，拉尔夫·韦斯特。
OK. I stayed up two extra hours to get all the details straight for you so you could be part of making a decision on our trip. I know you're making lots of decisions over there and I shouldn't bother you with this. It's just, I've been making all the decisions here for 10 months by myself.
好的。我多熬了两个小时，把所有细节都弄好了，这样你就能参与决定我们的行程。我知道你在那边要做很多决定，我不该拿这些琐事烦你。只是，过去10个月一直都是我一个人在做所有的决定。
When I called home the last time, Laura told me she'd just come back from taking our two daughters to the sports bar we would go to every Friday afternoon when I was there. It was a tradition of ours. And it moved me that she'd done this. But then Laura was saying that our four-year-old daughter, who has Down's Syndrome, began vomiting all over herself at the table. And our eight-year-old daughter kept saying, "Gross, gross, gross." And the waitress was horrified. And she couldn't find enough napkins. People all over the restaurant were looking away and covering their mouths.
上次我打电话回家时，劳拉告诉我，她刚带我们的两个女儿从周五下午我们常去的运动酒吧回来。那是我们的传统。她这么做让我很感动。但劳拉接着说，我们四岁的女儿（患有唐氏综合征）在餐桌上吐了一身。八岁的大女儿一直喊：“恶心，恶心，恶心。”服务员吓坏了，她怎么也找不到足够的餐巾纸。餐厅里的人都纷纷转过头，掩住口鼻。
When I got home, I ended up in Las Vegas at the Sweethearts' Wedding Chapel with my girlfriend of two years, getting married as her mother listened in on a cell phone. I spent like $5,000, ring not included, much of it at the Bellagio. The penthouse suite. It's like $500 or something dollars a night. We stayed for two. And then it was time to go. It was worse than leaving the first time.
我回家时，最后是在拉斯维加斯的“恋人婚礼教堂”跟我两年的女友结了婚，她母亲在电话里听着。我花了5000美元左右，还没算戒指，大部分是在百乐宫酒店花的。顶层豪华套房。大概一晚500多美元。我们住了两晚。然后就是离开的时候了。那比第一次离开时更难受。
I went home, and as glad as I was to be there, my heart sank when I saw my 17-year-old son, Joey, was driving around in a truck that had 160,000 miles on it. It was leaking oil and transmission fluid, had a plastic bag taped over a broken-out window. So we go looking for a truck. And golly, these cars are so expensive. The one we liked the most was at a Toyota place. It was a used grey Dodge, 25,000 miles on it. But the price was $17,000. Only $17,000, the salesman, a little ball of energy, had said. But there's no "only" about it.
我回到家，虽然很高兴能回来，但当我看到17岁的儿子乔伊开着一辆跑了16万英里的卡车时，我的心沉了下去。车在漏油和变速箱油，破窗户上还贴着塑料袋。于是我们去找卡车。天哪，这些车真贵。我们最看中的一辆在丰田车行。一辆灰色的二手道奇，跑了2.5万英里。但价格要1.7万美元。那个精力旺盛的推销员说：“才1.7万美元。”但这世上哪有什么“才”字。
One night I was sitting out on the porch by myself and thinking about it. And I was thinking, "You know, Randy, if you don't make it back for whatever reason, if you don't come back, what will Joey have to drive if you don't get him something before you leave?" I was alone on the porch, and I went back and forth on it. Fix the old truck, that I could afford. Or I could buy him something and be done with it. And at least when I go back to Iraq, I'll have a clear conscience that I did the right thing when I was home. So I bought him a $17,000 truck.
一天晚上，我一个人坐在门廊上想着这事。我在想：“你知道吗，兰迪，如果因为什么原因你没能回来，如果你回不来了，在你走之前没给他买辆车，乔伊以后开什么？”我一个人坐在门廊上，反反复复地想。修那辆旧卡车，我付得起。或者我可以直接买辆新的。至少当我回伊拉克时，我会问心无愧，因为我在家时做了正确的事。于是我给他买了那辆1.7万美元的卡车。
And let me tell you how I did this. This is great. This is how I surprised him. We find this truck and drive it and go away for a couple of days. I do all the paperwork while he's at school. Because I did it over the phone. I said, "Joey, let's drive back up to the Toyota place and see if that truck's still there." He said, "There ain't no need in going up there, Dad. We can't afford it. We already talked about it. It costs too much. I said, "Well, let's go talk to him and let's go see if we can get him down to $15,000 instead of $17,000." So we pull up there and the truck's moved because they're getting it ready for me to pick it up. And we walk up to one of salesman. And that guy didn't know me, and I asked him about the truck. And he said, "Oh somebody came by this morning and bought it."
我告诉你我是怎么做的。这太棒了。我是这么给他惊喜的。我们看了车，试驾了，然后走了几天。他上学时我把手续全办了，因为我是通过电话办的。我说：“乔伊，咱们去丰田车行看看那辆车还在不在。”他说：“爸，没必要去那儿。我们买不起。我们已经谈过了。太贵了。”我说：“好吧，咱们去跟他们谈谈，看看能不能砍到1.5万美元。”我们把车开过去，那辆车已经挪动了，因为他们正在做交付准备。我们走到一个推销员面前。那家伙不认识我，我问他车的事。他说：“哦，今天上午有人来把它买走了。”
Aw, you should have Joey's face. "I told you dad. I told you somebody bought it." And I said, "Well let's go inside and see." So we go inside and the little guy comes running up to me. He says, "Mr. Wadell, how you doing? Blah blah blah." And I said, "So I hear you sold that truck today." And he said, "Yeah. We sold it to you." Joey looked at me and I said, "Oh yeah. You own that truck outside." It turned out well.
哎呀，你该看看乔伊的脸。“我告诉过你了爸。我告诉你有人买走它了。”我说：“咱们进去看看吧。”我们走进屋，那小个子跑过来。“韦德尔先生，你好吗？巴拉巴拉。”我说：“听说你今天把那辆车卖了。”他说：“是啊。卖给你了。”乔伊看着我，我说：“噢，是的。外面的那辆车归你了。”结果挺圆满的。
In the first hours of my leave, I walked through the Atlanta airport and couldn't look anyone in the eye. The businessmen on cell phones, the families on vacation, all of it was too strange. "The normal abnormal," Major Cummings called Iraq. But this was exactly the opposite. The abnormal normal. I kept my eyes down. I made my way to a connecting flight home and the girlfriend that I wasn't sure I knew how to talk to anymore.
休假头几个小时，我在亚特兰大机场穿行，不敢看任何人的眼睛。打着手机的商人，去度假的家庭，一切都太陌生了。“正常的反常”，卡明斯少校这样称呼伊拉克。但这里却是恰恰相反：反常的正常。我一直低着头。我换乘飞机回到家，还有那个我已经不知道该如何交流的女友。
I'm going home too. But unlike the others, I'm not coming back. Five months after carrying Sergeant Emory down the stairs in Kamalaya, I couldn't do it anymore. This is my third deployment to Iraq. I've been here 34 months by my own count, just over 1,000 days. It doesn't matter to me anymore that I was one of 216's best soldiers. I need to go home. That's what combat stress said after I finally gave in and admitted that my thoughts had turned suicidal.
我也要回家了。但和别人不同，我不会再回来了。在卡马拉亚抱着埃莫里中士下楼五个月后，我实在撑不下去了。这是我第三次被部署到伊拉克。据我计算，我在这儿待了34个月，刚过1000天。我曾经是216营最好的士兵之一，但现在这对我来说已经不重要了。我需要回家。当我终于屈服并承认自己的思想变得有自杀倾向时，心理医生是这么说的。
So I'm finished. Down to my final hours. Packed, weaponless, under escort. Waiting for the helicopter that'll take me away to a wife who just told me on the phone, "I'm scared of what you might do." "You know I'd never hurt you," I said. Hung up and wandered around the base. Got a hair cut, came back to my room where I'm thinking, "But what if she's right? What if I snap someday?" It's a thought that makes me feel sick.
所以，我完了。最后几个小时。打包，缴械，有护送。等着直升机把我带走，带去见那个在电话里对我说“我怕你会做出什么傻事”的妻子。“你知道我永远不会伤害你，”我说。挂掉电话，在基地里徘徊。理了个发，回到房间，我想：“但如果她是错的呢？如果我哪天崩溃了呢？”这个想法让我感到恶心。
You spend 1,000 days, it gets to the point where it's Groundhog Day. Every day is over and over. The heat, the smell, the language. And I remember when it wasn't that way. I remember the initial invasion when it wasn't that way. I was in the front seat of the greatest movie I'd ever seen in my life. I remember the firefights in my second deployment. I loved it. Any time I got shot at in a firefight, it's the sexiest feeling there is.
待上1000天，你会觉得生活成了《土拨鼠之日》。每一天都在重复。炎热、气味、语言。我记得还没变成这样的时候。我记得刚入侵时，那时候不是这样的。我坐在我一生看过最伟大电影的前排座位。我记得第二次部署时的交火，我喜欢那样。任何时候在枪战中被射击，那都是最刺激的感觉。
But this deployment I began to feel bad early on. I'd get in the Humvee and be driving down the road and I'd feel my heart pulsing up in my throat. And that was the start of it. And then Emory happened. Then Crow. And then I was in a succession of explosions. Then a bullet skimmed across my thighs. Then Doster happened. And then I was waking up thinking, "Holy [BLEEP] I'm still here and it's misery." It's hell. I didn't give a [BLEEP]. I wanted it over as soon as possible, whether they did it or I did it.
但这次部署，我很早就开始感觉不好了。我会坐进悍马车，行驶在路上，感觉到心脏在喉咙处狂跳。那是一切的开始。然后是埃莫里出事。然后是克劳。接着我经历了一连串的爆炸。然后一颗子弹擦过我的大腿。然后多斯特出事了。接着我醒来时想：“该死，我还在，真是煎熬。”那是地狱。我根本不在乎了。我只想这一切尽快结束，不管是他们结束我还是我自己结束。
The amazing thing is that no one knew. There was all this stuff going on, pounding heart, panicked breathing, sweating palms, electric eyes. And no one regarded me as anything other than the soldier I'd always been. The one who never complained. Who hoisted bleeding soldiers onto my back. Who'd suddenly begun insisting on being in the right front seat of the lead Humvee on every mission. Not because I wanted to be dead, but because that's what selfless leaders would do. And I was the great Sergeant Schumann, who one day walked into the aid station, went through the door marked Combat Stress, and asked for help from James Tczap. And then I was on my way home.
令人惊奇的是没人知道。这中间发生了很多事，心脏狂跳、惊恐呼吸、手心冒汗、双眼充血。但没人把我当成那个我一直以来的士兵。那个从不抱怨的人。那个把流血的士兵背在背上的人。那个突然开始坚持要在每次任务中坐在领先悍马车前排座位的人。不是因为我想死，而是因为这是无私的领导者该做的。而我就是伟大的舒曼中士，直到有一天，我走进医疗站，穿过标有“战斗压力”的门，向詹姆斯·特扎普寻求帮助。然后我就在回家的路上了。
I remember what Tczap had told me. "With your stature, maybe you've opened the door for a lot of guys to come in." It made me feel really good. But I still felt awful yesterday when I told one of my team leaders to round up everyone in my squad. "What did we do now?" he asked. "You didn't do anything. Just get them together." They came into my room and I shut the door and told them I was leaving the following day. I said, "I don't even know what I'm going through. I just know that I don't feel right." That's what I told them. "That's why I'm leaving." "How long?" one of them asked. I told them I didn't know. "I might not be coming back." And they rallied around me then. Shook my hand, grabbed me by the arm, patted me on the back, saying whatever 19 and 20-year-olds could think of to say. "Take care of yourself," "Drink a beer for me." I never felt so guilt-ridden in my life.
我记得特扎普对我说的：“以你的地位，也许你为很多人打开了一扇求助的大门。”这让我感觉非常好。但昨天当我叫团队负责人召集我小队的所有人时，我依然感到糟糕。“我们又做错了什么？”他问。“没做错什么。把他们聚在一起就好。”他们走进我的房间，我关上门，告诉他们我明天就要走了。我说：“我甚至不知道自己在经历什么。我只知道我感觉不对劲。”这就是我告诉他们的。“这就是我离开的原因。”“多久回来？”其中一个问。我告诉他我不知道。“我可能不会回来了。”那一刻他们围住我。握我的手，抓住我的胳膊，拍我的背，说着所有19、20岁孩子能想到的安慰的话。“照顾好自己”，“替我喝杯啤酒”。我这辈子从没感到如此内疚。
Early this morning the rest of the squad drove off on a mission, leaving me behind. After they disappeared I didn't know what to do with myself. I went to my room, turned up the air conditioner full blast. Started watching Apocolypse Now on my computer. I packed my meds. I left some beef jerky and smoked oysters, packages of mac and cheese for the guys. Finally it was time to go to the helicopter. My stomach hurt as I made my way across the base. I felt myself becoming nauseated.
今天清晨，小队其他人开车去执行任务，留下我一个人。他们消失后，我不知道该做什么。我回到房间，把空调开到最大。开始在电脑上看《现代启示录》。我打包了药物。留了一些牛肉干、烟熏牡蛎和通心粉给队员们。终于到了去直升机那边的时间了。我穿过基地时肚子疼。感到一阵恶心。
At the landing area, other soldiers from other battalions were lined up. And when the helicopter landed, everyone was allowed to board, except me. I didn't understand. "Next one's yours," I was told. When it came a few minutes later I realized why I'd had to wait. It had a big red cross on the side. It was the helicopter for the injured and the dead. And that was me. I was injured. I was dead. I was done.
在降落区，来自其他营的士兵列队排着。当直升机降落时，所有人都被允许登机，除了我。我不明白。“下一架是你的，”有人告诉我。几分钟后它来了，我明白了为什么要等。它的侧面有一个大红十字。这是给伤员和死者准备的直升机。那就是我。我受了伤。我死了。我完了。
I was home now, too. Sitting on my front porch since waking up in the dark to the sound of explosions. Just thunder, I realized. So I went outside to see my first rainstorm in months. My wife said, "We're going to have to get the umbrellas out for the girls." And I wondered whether the umbrellas were still in the same place as when I left. At Rudina's, the coffee shop where I like to go, one of the regulars clapped me on the back and motioned to a friend, "Come on over me and meet Brent Cummings," he said. "He's just back from Iraq. He's a hero."
我也到家了。自打从黑暗中被爆炸声惊醒，我就一直坐在前门廊上。那是雷声，我意识到。于是我走出门，看了几个月来的第一场雨。我妻子说：“我们得把伞拿出来给女孩们用。”我纳闷伞是不是还在我走时的那个位置。在鲁迪娜咖啡馆，我常去的地方，一个常客拍了拍我的背，朝朋友示意：“过来跟我见见布伦特·卡明斯，”他说，“他刚从伊拉克回来。他是英雄。”
I'd sit on the porch and listen to the automatic lawn sprinklers that Laura had mentioned in an email that she was having installed. I'd sit in the living room and listen to my daughters play the piano that Laura had mentioned she was thinking of buying. One day I said to Laura, "How much do you want to know?"
我会坐在门廊上，听着劳拉在邮件里提到的她让人装的自动草坪喷头。我会坐在客厅里，听着女儿们弹奏劳拉说她打算买的钢琴。有一天，我对劳拉说：“你想知道多少？”
He hung up his uniform, and I was just sitting on the bed watching him. And suddenly he started to cry. "It's so stupid, Laura. It's so stupid." That's all he kept saying over and over.
他挂上制服，我坐在床边看着他。突然他开始哭。“这太蠢了，劳拉。这太蠢了。”他一遍又一遍地说。
I felt better after that.
之后我感觉好多了。
It wasn't the 18 days that Ralph would be here but the 400 days that he would not. It's boxes of Christmas decorations that I'd hauled down from the attic and needed to put up. It's thickening ice on the sidewalk and steps, and where in the world was the big bag of ice melter we bought last year? It's the lights flickering in the storm, and where were the AA batteries for the flashlight in case the electricity went out? Here were the C batteries, here were the AAAs, but where were the AAs?
重要的不是拉尔夫回来的那18天，而是他不在的那400天。是从阁楼拖下来需要挂好的圣诞装饰盒。是人行道和台阶上变厚的冰，去年买的大袋除冰剂到底在哪儿？是风暴中闪烁的灯光，万一停电，手电筒的AA电池在哪儿？这里有C电池，这里有AAA，但AA在哪儿呢？
The framed photograph of Ralph on top of the refrigerator also needed batteries to power the motion sensor that triggered the memory chip on which he'd recorded a message so the kids wouldn't forget his voice.
冰箱顶上拉尔夫的照片框也需要电池供电，才能触发那个记忆芯片，他录了一段话，好让孩子们不会忘记他的声音。
Hey! What are you doing over there? I see you! I see you!
嘿！你在那儿干什么？我看见你了！我看见你了！
He'd recorded it, trying to be funny, after I said that his original message about how much he missed them might be too sad. And it worked. He got on a plane to go to Iraq, and the kids came home and walked into the kitchen and heard him saying, "I see you." They went out and came back in. "I see you." They woke up the next morning and came into the kitchen for breakfast. "I see you."
他说他想表现得幽默点，在我说他最初关于有多想念他们的留言太伤感之后。效果还不错。他坐飞机去伊拉克了，孩子们回家走进厨房，听见他说：“我看见你了。”他们出去又回来。“我看见你了。”第二天早上醒来，走进厨房吃早餐。“我看见你了。”
Every morning there he was. Even before I had coffee. "I see you." I began ducking when I came into the kitchen. What could I do, though? I couldn't turn the photo upside-down. I couldn't take the batteries out or cover the sensor or do anything that would seem disrespectful of the circumstances that had led to the buying of the frame and the recording of the message. "I see you. I see you. I see you. I see you."
每天早上他都在那儿。在我喝咖啡之前。“我看见你了。”我走进厨房时开始下意识低头。但我能怎么办呢？我不能把照片倒扣过来。我不能取出电池，或者遮住传感器，或者做任何显得不尊重当时购买相框和录音环境的事情。“我看见你了。我看见你了。我看见你了。我看见你了。”
And then one day the batteries ran out. And I meant to replace them, but now it's months later and anyway they were probably AAs. And if I could find any AAs I'd better put them in the flashlight because the storm is getting worse.
终于有一天电池用完了。我本打算换上，但现在已经是几个月后了，而且它们大概是AA电池。如果能找到AA电池，我最好还是放在手电筒里，因为风暴越来越严重了。
In April, when Ralph wrote to tell me that Jake Hadgemat died, he didn't go into detail about how. And when I wrote back, I didn't go into detail about painting Easter eggs with the kids. In July, when the 216 was being attacked several times a day, I didn't dwell on my own drama, that the kids and I were driving home from out of state and the car died. And in September, I didn't tell him much about the Colonel's wife who'd approached me and asked. "How are you doing?" "I'm doing OK." "Are you sure?" "Yes." "Are you sure?" "Yes. I'm doing OK." "No you're not. You're not doing OK."
四月，当拉尔夫写信告诉我杰克·哈杰马特阵亡时，他没详细说明过程。当我回信时，我也没细说和孩子们一起画复活节彩蛋的事。七月，当216营每天被袭击好几次时，我没有纠结于自己的琐事，比如我和孩子们从外州开车回家时车子坏了。九月，我没跟他多提上校夫人找我的事。她问：“你最近怎么样？”“我还好。”“你确定？”“是的。”“你确定？”“是的，我还好。”“不，你并不好。你过得并不好。”
It would have been an uncomfortable conversation any time. But making it worse was the setting, the memorial service for the three soldiers. And what am I supposed to say? I'm sick of being a single parent? I'm sick of not having sex? Is that when I say? That life sucks? Instead, I keep anything like that to myself. I wasn't going to tell a colonel's wife that. And I'm not going to tell Ralph, who I'm sure needs me to be nothing other than upbeat. Just like there's no way I'm going to tell him how much work these videos are.
这在任何时候都是一场让人尴尬的谈话。更糟糕的是环境：那场三名士兵的追悼会。我该说什么？我厌倦了做单亲妈妈？我厌倦了没有性生活？是这时候说吗？生活烂透了？相反，我把这类想法藏在心里。我不会对上校夫人说这些。我也不会对拉尔夫说，我相信他需要我表现得积极向上。就像我不可能告诉他这些视频处理起来有多麻烦一样。
[CHILDREN SINGING "HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO YOU"]
[孩子们唱着“祝你生日快乐”]
That the boys prefer to be watching TV or playing with friends. That no one would say anything and I had to prompt them with whispered commands. I won't tell him about the branch that just missed the car, or the way I attack the ice on the sidewalk with a hammer and a knife because I couldn't find the melter. I won't tell him that before I could find a moment to write him, the night had been a parade of footsteps and flushing toilets and coughs. And me, trying to soothe our little anxious boys by saying, "Good night my handsome men."
孩子们宁愿看电视或找朋友玩。没人会说话，我不得不低声指挥他们。我不会告诉他那根差点砸到车的树枝，或者因为找不到除冰剂，我用锤子和刀子去砸人行道上积冰的样子。我不会告诉他，在我能挤出时间写信给他之前，那个夜晚充斥着脚步声、冲厕所声和咳嗽声。而我，试图哄我们焦虑的小男孩们，说着：“晚安，我帅气的男人们。”
I hate this war and what it has done to my life. I won't tell him that either. Instead, at 12:44 AM, exhausted, I write, "Hi love. Well guess who loves you? Me and A, J, and G. I hope you enjoyed the pictures I sent earlier. Quite a remarkable storm." He'll be home in January. He's due to leave Baghdad in 16 days. I'm worried about January. Who will he be?
我恨这场战争，以及它对我生活造成的破坏。这些我也不会告诉他。相反，在凌晨12:44，筋疲力尽的我写道：“嗨，亲爱的。猜猜谁爱你？我和A、J还有G。希望你喜欢我之前发给你的照片。这真是一场了不起的风暴。”他一月份就回来了。他预定16天后离开巴格达。我担心一月份的事。他会变成什么样？
"I'm proud of you," I write him. Your wife, Stephanie.
“我为你感到骄傲，”我写道。你的妻子，斯蒂芬妮。
Excerpts from David Finkel's great non-fiction book about the Iraq War, The Good Soldiers . The excerpts were read by actors Michael Chernus, Fran Tarr, Patch Dara, Danny Barbone, John Ellison Conley, Eric Menel, Alec Beard, Wendy Door and Connie Britain.
以上节选自大卫·芬克尔关于伊拉克战争的非虚构名著《好兵》。节选由演员迈克尔·切努斯、弗兰·塔尔、帕奇·达拉、丹尼·巴伯恩、约翰·埃利森·康利、埃里克·梅内尔、亚历克·比尔德、温迪·多尔和康妮·布里顿朗读。
[MUSIC - "BABY, WON'T YOU PLEASE COME HOME?"  BY PRESERVATION HALL JAZZ BAND AND AMY LEVERE]
[音乐 - 佩扎韦申霍尔爵士乐队和艾米·勒维尔演奏的《宝贝，你请回来好吗？》]
Coming up, when the question in the war becomes, "What would Carol Brady do?" That's one short minute away, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
稍后回来，当战争中的问题变成“卡萝尔·布雷迪会怎么做？”节目将在芝加哥WBEZ电台和公共广播国际公司继续播出，仅需一分钟。
Welcome back. I'm Nancy Updike sitting in for Ira Glass. He's out reporting a story, a great story. He'll be back next week. It's This American Life . And we have a theme this week, like we do every week. Today's is, "Will They Know Me Back Home?" Two stories about war and after war.
欢迎回来。我是南希·厄普代克，代艾拉·格拉斯主持。他去为各位报道一个故事，一个精彩的故事。他下周会回来。这里是《美国生活》。我们每周都有一个主题，今天的主题是：“回到家乡，他们还能认出我吗？”两个关于战争及战后的故事。
This second story has stuck in my head for six months. Last summer I was in Iraq with another reporter, Larry Kaplow, and our interpreter was a woman named Sarah. Usually the interpreter in a radio story is just a voice when they're on the air, not a full-fledged person. But after the Iraq show we put together aired, we got more mail about Sarah than about almost anyone else in the show, even though her own personal story was on the air for less than a minute.
这第二个故事在我脑海里挥之不去已经六个月了。去年夏天，我和另一位记者拉里·卡普洛在伊拉克，我们的翻译是一位叫萨拉的女性。通常广播故事里的翻译只是个声音，不是一个完整的人。但在我们制作的关于伊拉克的节目播出后，我们收到了比节目中任何人都要多得多的关于萨拉的邮件，尽管她个人的故事在节目里出现的时间不到一分钟。
Sarah makes an impression. And it's partly because who she was before the war still comes through. This warm, chatty housewife raising her two boys, getting up every morning and putting on clothes that will be familiar to anyone who's ever spent the whole day at home.
萨拉给人留下了深刻的印象。部分原因在于战前的她依然清晰可见。那位温暖、健谈的家庭主妇，抚养着两个儿子，每天早上起床，穿上那些曾经当过全职主妇的人都很熟悉的衣服。
Track suit. And pajamas. And then a uniform.
运动服。还有睡衣。然后是一套制服。
The uniform was an American military uniform. And Sarah's laughing because she can still barely believe the arc of her life over the last seven years. She was part of the same grueling period of the war that the soldiers in David Finkel's book faced. In fact, her story overlaps with their time in Iraq almost exactly. But unlike them, she not only wasn't a soldier, she'd never worked outside her home in her life. And she went from that into the middle of one of the most violent stretches of the war.
这套制服是美国军装。萨拉笑是因为她几乎不敢相信自己过去七年的人生轨迹。她经历的战争时期与大卫·芬克尔书中的士兵所面临的极其艰苦的时期是同一阶段。事实上，她的故事与他们在伊拉克的服役时间几乎完全重合。但与他们不同的是，她不仅不是士兵，甚至这辈子从未在家里以外的地方工作过。她就那样置身于战争最血腥的一段时期之中。
So Sarah's story, the story you're about to hear, is about an ordinary woman with no heroic ambitions who took on a role for which she was the unlikeliest of candidates and thrived in it.
所以萨拉的故事，你们即将听到的故事，讲述的是一个没有英雄抱负的普通女性，扮演了一个最不可能由她担任的角色，并且做得非常出色。
Before the war, Sarah's marriage was unhappy. She's blunt about it. And the war made it worse. By the end of 2006, Sarah and her family had been bombed out of their house-- they were Sunnis driven out by Shiite militias-- and militia members had taken over her husband's car repair business. The family had to rebuild from nothing. They were broke and sometimes hungry, including the kids, Mustafa, 16 years old, and Becker, who just turned 10. The streets were dangerous, but someone needed to get a job. And Sarah and her husband were arguing all the time.
战前，萨拉的婚姻不幸福。她直言不讳。而战争使情况变得更糟。到2006年底，萨拉一家被炸毁了房子——他们是被什叶派民兵赶走的逊尼派——民兵成员还接管了她丈夫的汽车修理生意。全家不得不从零开始重建。他们身无分文，有时甚至饿肚子，包括孩子们，16岁的穆斯塔法和刚满10岁的贝克。街道很危险，但总得有人出去工作。萨拉和丈夫一直在争吵。
Sometimes I was really, you know, try to clear his scary vision. He was so scared from the-- I don't blame him. It was a hard time for everyone. But many of the fathers go every morning outside, and they work and they come back to their houses safe. So I was talking with him like, "Hey, I am here to support you. You have to work. You have to go bring money or food for your boys. We are all in very hard time. Not only us, all Iraq. So you have to go outside." He said, "You want them to kill me?"
有时我真的，你知道，试图消除他恐怖的阴影。他被吓坏了——我并不怪他。那对每个人来说都是艰难的时期。但很多父亲每天早上都出门，他们工作，然后平安回到家中。所以我对他说：“嘿，我在这儿支持你。你必须工作。你得去为孩子们挣钱或带回食物。我们都处于非常艰难的时期，不仅是我们，整个伊拉克都是。所以你必须出门。”他说：“你想让他们杀了我吗？”
Really I had many arguments with my husband. I really-- when I get upset I raise my voice. And he was raising his voice more than I raise my voice.
我和丈夫确实吵过很多次架。我真的……当我心烦时会提高嗓门。而他提高嗓门比我更厉害。
Sarah had gotten married at 19. And like I said, she'd never worked outside the home, at her husband's insistence. For her, this was part of the bitterness at the core of their marriage. He'd pressured her to drop out of college with only one year to go after promising before they'd married that he would let her finish. Work was always out of the question. Until now.
萨拉19岁结婚。正如我所说，在丈夫的坚持下，她从未在外工作过。对她来说，这是他们婚姻核心苦涩的一部分。他曾迫使她在大三那年退学，尽管结婚前他承诺让她读完书。工作一直是绝对禁止的。直到现在。
A new opportunity suddenly came up. American soldiers happened to hear Sarah's younger son, Becker, speaking English, and they asked where he'd learned it, which was from his mother. Sarah has an ear for languages. She studied German in college. But she'd learned some English in school, too. And she built it up watching movies, listening to American music.
一个新的机会突然出现了。美国士兵偶然听到萨拉的小儿子贝克说英语，便问他是从哪儿学的，答案是跟他母亲学的。萨拉有语言天赋。她在大学学过德语。但在学校也学过一些英语。她是靠看电影、听美国音乐建立起的语言基础。
The Americans asked Sarah's husband to send her in. They needed interpreters. This was 2007, four years into the war, and interpreters were targets for Al Qaeda and other Sunni militants and for Shiite militias. Sarah was terrified. But the family needed money. So she took the test and was offered a contract. Starting salary: $1,150 a month. Enough for the family to live on and build up savings again. That was the good part of the contract.
美国人叫萨拉的丈夫派她去。他们需要翻译。那是2007年，战争进行到第四个年头，翻译是基地组织、其他逊尼派武装分子和什叶派民兵的目标。萨拉吓坏了。但家里需要钱。于是她参加了测试，并获得了一份合同。起薪：每月1150美元。足够维持全家生活并重新积累积蓄。这是合同好的部分。
The contract said 27 days in the camp and then four days vacation. So it's a very long time for me to leave my kids alone in the house.
合同规定在基地待27天，然后休息4天。所以对我来说，把孩子们单独留在家里是非常长的一段时间。
So you would be living on the base with the Americans for 27 days, and then get 4 days at home? You couldn't commute back and forth and see them at night, even?
所以你得和美国人一起住在基地里27天，然后回家待4天？你甚至不能每天往返回家看看他们？
No, no, no. I really worried about this item in the contract.
不，不，不。我真的很担心合同里的这一条款。
But I start work with them and I found myself in a room smaller than this one, alone and I spend only one night and then I want to quit the next morning. I wanted to take my bag and run away to my house. Because each time I hear the American soldiers in the bath laughing and talking, I said, "What am I doing here? This is not my place. My place with my boys in the house. How can I just bear 27 days without seeing my kids?"
但我开始和他们一起工作，发现自己待在一个比这间办公室还小的房间里，独自一人。只待了一晚，第二天早上我就想辞职。我想拿上包逃回家。因为每次我听见美国士兵在洗澡时说笑，我就说：“我在这儿干什么？这儿不是我的地方。我的地方是和孩子们待在家里。我怎么能忍受27天见不到孩子？”
And then one of the Iraqi interpreters, he saw me so confused. And I told them this is the first day for me. I want to quit. I want to leave. So he says, this is normal thing. We all felt the same way you feel now. So just relax and give yourself time.
然后，一个伊拉克翻译看见我非常困惑。我告诉他这是我的第一天。我想辞职。我想离开。于是他说，这是正常的事。我们所有人都经历过和你现在一样的感觉。所以放松点，给自己点时间。
Picture a woman in her late 30s with a wide face. Five foot three, but solid, not fragile. Huge smile. Now wearing fatigues, bulletproof vest, medic bag, wrap-around shrapnel-resistant glasses and a helmet, 40 pounds of gear. Sarah is her nickname. All Iraqi interpreters pick nicknames. The fewer people who know their real names, the better. She picked Sarah. It's easy to pronounce in English and in Arabic.
想象一个快40岁的女性，面容宽阔。身高五英尺三英寸（约1.6米），但很结实，不脆弱。笑容灿烂。现在穿着迷彩服、防弹背心，带着医疗包、环绕式防弹眼镜和头盔，负重40磅（约18公斤）。萨拉是她的昵称。所有伊拉克翻译都用昵称。知道他们真名的人越少越好。她选了“萨拉”。在英语和阿拉伯语里都很容易发音。
Sarah was an interpreter for Alpha Company 177, but she did more than just interpret. She gathered key information that became intel for the unit. Remember, this was the surge. Baghdad was on the edge of all-out civil war, and the surge plan was to send US military outfits, like Alpha Company, out into the middle of dangerous areas with constant IED and sniper attacks to try and stabilize them.
萨拉是Alpha连177的翻译，但她做的工作远不止翻译。她搜集关键信息，成为了该部队的情报来源。记住，这是增兵时期。巴格达正处于全面内战的边缘，增兵计划是将美国军事单位（如Alpha连）派往危险地区中间，面对不断的IED和狙击手袭击，试图稳住局势。
Alpha Company landed in southwest Rashid. At the time it was a confusing churn of different militias, including the powerful Mahdi Army, the Jaish al-Mahdi, who were trying to control the area. Kidnapping and killing were common. And the only way for the Americans to fight was to get tips from informants, ordinary local people who were frightened all the time. Of the militias, of the Americans.
Alpha连降落在拉希德西南部。当时那里充斥着各种混乱的民兵，包括强大的马赫迪军，他们在争夺该地区的控制权。绑架和杀戮很普遍。美国人反击的唯一方式就是从线人那里获取情报，这些线人都是普通的当地人，他们一直生活在恐惧中，既怕民兵，也怕美国人。
Sarah's job was to try to convince these frightened people to talk. Her new boss, Captain Bill Higgins-- he's actually now a major-- gave her an assignment. Call up this guy. He doesn't want to talk, but just try.
萨拉的工作就是试着说服这些惊恐的人开口。她的新上司比尔·希金斯上尉——他现在是少校了——给了她一个任务。给这家伙打个电话。他不想说话，但试试看。
Try to talk with him. Try to ask him about the neighborhood. And I called him and I talked with him. "I'm Sarah. I'm working with the Americans. You know, these things. And I ask him about the neighborhood, his neighborhood. And he starts to give me his real name, his job, all the information about the bad guys in his neighborhood. So when I told the captain after I finished my call, he was really surprised. He said, "Sarah, we tried with him since six months. Tried to get even his name. And he refused to give it to us. This is something unbelievable."
试着跟他交流。试着问他关于社区的情况。我给他打了电话。“我是萨拉。我和美国人一起工作。你知道的，就是这些事。”我问他关于他那个社区的情况。他开始给我真实姓名、工作，所有关于他社区里那些坏人的信息。所以我告诉队长时，他非常惊讶。他说：“萨拉，我们试了半年都没能让他说出名字。他拒绝透露。这简直不可思议。”
It was the first time for me to recognize and realize that there is other things I can do in addition to be a housewife, a good housewife. I start to feel all this energy inside me, all these good things inside me. So yes, there is something else. I can do  it. And within the right way.
那是我第一次认识到并意识到，除了做一个好主妇，我还能做其他事。我开始感觉到内心所有的能量，所有的好东西。所以是的，还有别的事。我能做到。而且是以正确的方式。
Major Higgins told me it really was unbelievable how good Sarah was at getting people to open up to her. They trusted her. They liked talking to her. Major Higgins felt that way. Sarah was approachable, sympathetic, funny, and unexpected. Like running into your favorite sister or aunt in a war zone. Even though she was dressed in fatigues, as soon as she started talking, it was clear to people that she knew their world and she knew them. She used to be them.
希金斯少校告诉我，萨拉在让人敞开心扉方面做得极其出色，这确实令人难以置信。人们信任她。他们喜欢和她聊天。希金斯少校也有同感。萨拉平易近人、富有同情心、有趣且出人意料。就像在战区遇到了你最喜欢的姐妹或阿姨。尽管她身穿迷彩服，但只要她一开口，人们就很清楚她了解他们的世界，了解他们。因为她过去就是他们中的一员。
Let's see, I spent 17 years in the kitchen, making food for the family and guests all the time. So this is, you know, a big step for me, to get out from all these things to a new world.
让我想想，我花了17年待在厨房里，一直为家人和客人做饭。所以这对我来说，是走出这一切迈向新世界的一大步。
It was really a hard seven months in my life, and the most wonderful seven months in my life. Sometimes we cannot sleep for days, working all the day and night. Talking with the sources, get information, make plans, raid houses.
那确实是我生命中艰难的七个月，也是我生命中最美妙的七个月。有时我们几天不能睡觉，整天整夜地工作。与线人交谈、获取情报、制定计划、突袭房屋。
Sarah's world flipped. Everything that had seemed overwhelming in the beginning became normal. Militias, informants, raids, IEDs, gunfire, dead bodies, and working around the clock. 27 days in a row of this. And then four days off. And not even fully off. She gave trusted informants or sources her personal cell phone number. She found herself struggling to get back into the quiet rhythm that used to be her whole life. Making meals, cleaning the house, being a wife, a sister, a mom.
萨拉的世界颠倒了。起初一切看似不可逾越的困难都变得正常了。民兵、线人、突袭、IED、枪声、尸体，还有全天候的工作。连续27天这样。然后休息4天。甚至这休息也不完整。她把个人手机号码给了信任的线人或消息源。她发现自己很难再回到曾经那种平静的节奏。做饭、打扫卫生、做一个妻子、姐妹和妈妈。
Many times-- believe me, and I'm really sorry to say that, I don't want to hurt anyone-- many of the times, they're talking and my mind thinking of this source. I have to call him and talk with him. Try to take more information. I forgot to ask this informer about this thing. And I have to ask him.
很多时候——相信我，我很抱歉这么说，我不想伤害任何人——很多时候，他们在说话，而我的心思在想那个线人。我得给他打电话跟他聊聊。试着获取更多信息。我忘了问那个线人关于那件事的情况。我必须问他。
So you were thinking about work while your relatives are talking about their lives and--
所以当你的亲戚在聊他们的生活时，你在想工作？
Yes. Yes. Many times I miss what they talking about. The problem for me was even when I was in my vacation, people keep calling me. And this is-- it didn't let me switch off all the these things and be a mom instead of being interpreter. One of the times when I was in a vacation, Becker asked me to do his favorite food-- chicken in the oven, with rice, of course-- and at the same time I got a call from a source. She starts to tell me something so important about weapon caches in the area. And I'm just holding the phone in one hand, and I try to put the tray in the oven.
是的。是的。很多次我错过了他们在聊什么。对我有问题的是，即使在休假时，人们也一直给我打电话。这让我没法彻底关掉这一切，回归做一个妈妈，而不是翻译。有一次休假，贝克请求我做他最爱吃的食物——烤箱烤鸡，当然要配米饭——就在同时，我接到了一个线人的电话。她开始告诉我一些关于该地区武器库的重要信息。我一手拿着电话，一手试图把烤盘放进烤箱。
You can see where this ends. She burns herself. She's still got the scar. But listen to her voice. She's thrilled. She wasn't just good at her job. She loved her job. On that phone call, the information she got while getting burned was so important she left her vacation early.
你可以预见结果。她烫伤了自己。现在还有伤疤。但听听她的声音。她非常兴奋。她不仅擅长工作，而且热爱工作。在那通电话里，她在被烫伤的同时获得的情报太重要了，以至于她提前结束了假期。
It was really a big day for us. We captured about 18 leaders in the same night.
那对我们来说真的是很重要的一天。我们在同一个晚上抓住了大约18名头目。
Sarah became indispensable. Out of the four or five interpreters the unit worked with regularly, she was the top. She was the one that Major Higgins and his operations officer wanted at their meetings with local sheikhs and other leaders. They sought her opinion as well as her interpreting skills. And her work with informants was crucial. Major Higgins says he's certain some of the people who called, especially women, would never have talked to a male interpreter. Sarah's letters of praise from American military officers are effusive and consistent. They wrote, "Her work has directly led to identifying many criminal actors and capturing them. We've learned that Sarah is feared by local criminals. Sarah unhesitatingly faced the same dangers as our soldiers. She's earned the trust and confidence of everyone in the unit."
萨拉变得不可或缺。在部队经常合作的四五名翻译中，她是顶尖的。她是希金斯少校和作战参谋在与当地酋长及其他领袖会面时想要带上的人。他们寻求她的建议，而不仅仅是她的翻译技巧。她与线人的合作至关重要。希金斯少校说他确信，有些人，特别是女性，绝不会跟男翻译交谈。萨拉从美国军官那里得到的表扬信既热烈又一致。他们写道：“她的工作直接导致识别并抓捕了许多犯罪分子。我们了解到萨拉让当地犯罪分子感到恐惧。萨拉毫不犹豫地面对与我们士兵同样的危险。她赢得了部队中每个人的信任和信心。”
The letters also talk about how hard Sarah worked. Major Higgins sometimes let her kids come to the compound and stay with her for a few days when the long separations got too difficult. Her husband came a couple of times, too. Sarah later overheard him talking to the kids about it.
信中还提到萨拉工作有多努力。希金斯少校有时会让她把孩子们带到大院里，当长期分离变得太痛苦时，让他们陪她几天。她丈夫也来过几次。萨拉后来无意中听到他跟孩子们谈论这件事。
He said, "I really shocked when I saw your mother do all this work all the time, day and night. So God help her and protect her."
他说：“当我看到你们母亲一直如此努力地工作时，我真的很震惊。所以愿上帝保佑她、保护她。”
The word empowerment has a quaintness about it now in the US, as though it's forever rendered in a '70s-era font. But there's no other word for what happened to Sarah. She became empowered. She used to be embarrassed to talk to strangers. Now she could talk to anyone. And when she did, everyone listened. Her world had become huge. For Sarah, it was a change that would come at a staggering personal cost. And she saw others pay a price for their courage, also.
“赋权”这个词现在在美国听起来有点古雅，仿佛永远停留在70年代的字体里。但对于萨拉身上发生的事，找不到别的词了。她被赋权了。她过去羞于与陌生人交谈。现在她能与任何人交流。而且当她开口时，每个人都在听。她的世界变得巨大。对萨拉来说，这是一个以令人震惊的个人代价为前提的改变。而她也看到其他人为他们的勇气付出了代价。
Sarah called up a woman in the area one day at the captain's request.
有一天，在队长的要求下，萨拉给该地区的一名妇女打了电话。
He said, "Sarah, this woman really has good information about a very bad area in the sector. We need her." I told her, "I'm a mom too, and I have two boys. And I accept to do this work, and it was very dangerous, because someone needs to be serious with this area, with this country. It has to be me or you or anyone to bring the secure and the safe to the area."
他说：“萨拉，这个女人关于该地区一个非常糟糕的区域真的有很好的情报。我们需要她。”我告诉她：“我也是个母亲，有两个儿子。我接受这份工作，虽然非常危险，因为得有人对这个区域、这个国家认真负责。得是我，或者你，或者任何一个人，来给这个地区带来安全和保障。”
The woman agreed to talk, in spite of being frightened. She lived in a neighborhood where militia members often hid. From the back of her house she could see what was happening on the main street, people planting IEDs to catch US military vehicles. And from the front, she could see who and what was coming into the area. She was a great source, calling Sarah at home to tell her about weapons and militias. They became friends. And she told Sarah that the militias had a nickname for Sarah. The Lion.
尽管害怕，那个女人还是同意交谈。她住在一个民兵经常藏匿的街区。从屋后她可以看到主街上发生的事情，看到人们埋设IED来袭击美军车辆。从屋前，她可以看到什么人、什么车进入该区域。她是一个很棒的消息源，打电话回家告诉萨拉有关武器和民兵的信息。她们成了朋友。她告诉萨拉，民兵给萨拉取了个绰号：狮子。
One day the woman's husband called Sarah and said, "They came and took her. Militia leaders took her."
有一天，那位妇女的丈夫打电话给萨拉说：“他们来了，把她带走了。民兵头目把她带走了。”
I know the militias. They are savage and they torture everyone. They don't care about a woman or a kid or anything. And I feel guilt. I thought, maybe I am the reason for what she will suffer from. I just wanted to take her back to her kids. And so I was like a crazy. Talking, crying, and talking with the captain, begging him to find any way to go and try to find her. I called one of the double agent, who work with the American and work with me.
我了解那些民兵。他们是野蛮人，折磨每一个人。他们根本不在乎是女人还是孩子，什么都不在乎。我感到内疚。我想，也许我是造成她受苦的原因。我只想把她带回她的孩子们身边。所以我像疯了一样。不停说话、哭泣，跟队长说话，求他想尽一切办法去找到她。我给一个双重间谍打了电话，他既为美国人工作也为我工作。
Someone in the Jaish al-Mahdi who was working with you, working with the Americans?
马赫迪军里有人在为你工作，也在为美国人工作？
Yes. And I begged him, "Just tell me where they will take her. Tell me about the places where you keep the kidnapped people." So we're moving from house to house, and all the houses were empty. We spend maybe 2 days searching for her. And then her husband called me and said, "Hey Sarah, they called us and they said, we killed her." Really it was-- every time I remembered her I really say, she was the Lion, not me. I wasn't the Lion. She was the Lion. Yeah.
是的。我求他：“只要告诉我他们把她带去哪儿。告诉我你们关押被绑架者的地方。”我们从这间屋搜到那间屋，所有房子都空了。我们花了大约两天时间找她。然后她丈夫打电话给我说：“嘿，萨拉，他们给我们打电话说，他们杀了她。”真的……每次想起她，我都会说，她是狮子，不是我。我不是狮子。她是狮子。是的。
In the beginning of 2008, after Major Higgins and his group had rotated out and a new group had come in, Sarah's husband joined the Sons of Iraq. These were groups of Iraqis the Americans paid to fight alongside them, especially against Al Qaeda, in areas all over Baghdad and other parts of Iraq. The Sons of Iraq also manned checkpoints. Sarah worried about the kids with both parents gone a lot, and at dangerous jobs. But her husband said he would only work part of the day. And he'd be back in the house during after school hours. After he finished training, he worked for less than a month.
2008年初，希金斯少校那组人轮换回国，新一批人接手后，萨拉的丈夫加入了“伊拉克之子”。这些是美国人出钱雇用的伊拉克组织，让他们与美军并肩作战，特别是打击基地组织，遍布巴格达及伊拉克各地。“伊拉克之子”也负责把守检查站。萨拉担心孩子，因为父母双方都要经常外出，而且从事的都是危险工作。但她丈夫说他每天只工作半天。放学后他会回到家。受训完成后，他只干了不到一个月。
He was driving his car in one of the streets where they put their checkpoints, and two cars drive beside his car, with three men inside it, and they start to shoot on him and kill him in his car.
他正开着车行驶在他们设检查站的街道上，两辆车开到他车两侧，里面坐着三个男人，他们开始对他开枪，在车里杀了他。
I was shocked, really. I start to cry. My boys jumped in my mind, and I called Mustafa immediately and I asked him about Becker, and he told me he  is in the house with me. And I said, "Don't go anywhere, because I will come to you." And I was crying and he was confused and asked me, "What's going on, mom? Tell me what's going on."
我真的震惊了。我开始哭。孩子们马上浮现在我脑海里，我立刻给穆斯塔法打电话问贝克，他告诉我贝克和我在一起。我说：“哪儿也别去，我会去找你们。”我当时在哭，他很困惑问我：“怎么了妈妈？告诉我发生了什么？”
Many Sons of Iraq fighters were being killed at the time. But Sarah was horrified to learn from one of her informants that her husband was killed at least in part because of her work. The informant told her he saw militia members the day her husband died.
当时很多“伊拉克之子”的战士被杀。但萨拉惊恐地从线人那里得知，她丈夫被杀至少部分是因为她的工作。线人告诉她，她在丈夫去世那天看到了民兵成员。
He saw them celebrate after his killing and distribute candies and laughing call each other and congratulate each other, "Hey we killed Sarah's husband."
他看到他们在杀人后庆祝，分发糖果，笑着互相喊叫、祝贺：“嘿，我们杀了萨拉的丈夫。”
Sarah started trying to get herself and her sons out if Iraq, to emigrate to the US. With the help of Major Higgins and others from his unit, as well as people from the new group, she applied for a special visa using those recommendation letters I quoted earlier.
萨拉开始试图带着儿子们离开伊拉克，移民去美国。在希金斯少校等人的帮助下，她申请了特殊签证，用的就是我之前引用的那些推荐信。
But in the fall of 2008, as she was waiting to do her first interview to get the visa, something totally unexpected happened. In the afternoon of what seemed to be a normal work day, Sarah was taken to what she thought would be a routine screening. It happened every six months or so on the job, when she had to renew her security badge. But this time the questions, by an American interrogator, went on for hours and hours. Finally she was taken into custody and driven to a section of the Baghdad Airport she'd never been to before.
但在2008年秋天，正当她等待面试签证时，完全意想不到的事情发生了。在一个看似正常的工作日的下午，萨拉被带去接受她以为是常规的筛查。工作中每六个月左右都会有一次，她需要更新安全证件。但这次，美国审讯官的问题持续了几个小时又几个小时。最后她被拘留，被带到了巴格达机场她从未去过的地方。
They took me to the airport and then I found myself in a jail. I really tried to explain what's going on. No one answer me.
他们把我带到机场，然后发现自己进了监狱。我真的试图解释发生了什么。没人回答我。
She was in an American jail and she had no idea why. It was several days before she could even let her kids know where she was.
她身处美国监狱，却根本不知道原因。过了好几天，她才得以通知孩子们她在哪里。
They allowed us to just two minutes to tell our families where we are. So I called my Mustafa and I talked with him. And then I talked with my older sister. And I couldn't tell her that I'm in jail, really. I felt so shamed and I didn't know what to say. Even if I told her, I'm in a jail, I'm sure she will ask me, why you are in jail? I don't know what to say or answer.
他们只允许我们用两分钟告诉家人我们在哪儿。所以我给穆斯塔法打了电话，和他聊了聊。然后又和我大姐聊。我没法告诉她我在监狱里，真的。我觉得太丢脸了，不知道该说什么。即便我告诉她我在坐牢，我也确定她会问我为什么坐牢？我不知道该怎么说或回答。
So I told them, hey there is some information about me and they keep me here in the airport just to check this information, if it's true or not, and then they will release me.
所以我告诉他们，嘿，有一些关于我的信息，他们把我留在这里机场只是为了核实一下，看这些信息是否属实，然后就会释放我。
The Americans she'd been working with for the last year were preparing to rotate out of Iraq. She didn't hear from them.
过去一年和她一起工作的美国人正准备从伊拉克轮换回国。她没得到他们的消息。
Day by day I realized that I'm alone and I need to defend myself, by myself.
一天天过去，我意识到我是一个人，我需要自救。
Over weeks of questioning, Sarah figured out what was happening. She'd been accused by an anonymous Iraqi source of betraying the Americans she was working with. Taking money from militias, deliberately misinterpreting so militia members would be released, and sneaking militia members into the Sons of Iraq to spy on the Americans. By the time she got a chance to defend herself in front of a judge, she had been in prison for two months. The judge threw out the case for insufficient evidence. But it took another month for the paperwork to go through. And incredibly, in that month, her situation got worse. She was transferred from the American jail into Iraqi custody.
经过数周的审讯，萨拉弄清了发生了什么。她被匿名伊拉克线人指控背叛美国人。从民兵那里收钱，故意胡乱翻译以释放民兵成员，还把民兵成员引诱进“伊拉克之子”来监视美国人。当她终于有机会在法官面前自辩时，她已经在监狱里待了两个月。法官因证据不足驳回了案件。但办理文书又花了一个月。令人难以置信的是，在那一个月里，情况恶化了。她被从美国监狱转入伊拉克监护。
And really it was a terrible experience for me there in the Iraqi jail. I don't want to remember anything. That jail makes my hair grey, really.
在那里坐牢真的是一段可怕的经历。我不想记住任何事。那座监狱让我头发都白了，真的。
Those three months undid her. Not only the jails. Sarah had been keeping all her savings in a bag in her room at the camp where she'd worked with the Americans. Banks hadn't felt safe. Iraq was still unstable. And she hadn't wanted to leave it at her house. When her son Mustafa went to pick up her things from the camp while Sarah was sitting in jail, the money was gone.
那三个月摧毁了她。不仅是因为监狱。萨拉把所有的积蓄都放在她以前和美国人工作时营房里的一个包里。银行感觉不安全，伊拉克依然不稳定。她也不想把钱留在家里。当儿子穆斯塔法去取她的东西时，钱没了。
I said, "No way. There was all my saving money in the bag." He says, "No mom. The bag was empty."
我说：“不可能。我的积蓄全在那包里。”他说：“不，妈妈。包是空的。”
About $20,000 disappeared, she says. The family had lived frugally the entire time Sarah was working so she could save most of her paycheck. It was money she'd planned to use for them to emigrate, if necessary. Now they didn't even have it to live on.
她说，大约2万美元不见了。萨拉工作期间全家生活节俭，为了能省下大部分工资。那本来是她计划留着让他们移民用的钱。现在连生活费都没了。
There was a final blow. Even though the case against her has been dismissed, and Sarah had an exemplary work record, she's been blacklisted. The anonymous accusations are now a seemingly permanent part of her US Defense Department file. She can't work for the US anymore, and her visa to America has been denied.
这是最后一击。尽管针对她的案件已被驳回，且萨拉有着模范工作记录，但她被列入了黑名单。匿名指控现在似乎成了她美国国防部档案中永久的一部分。她再也不能为美国工作了，去美国的签证也被拒绝。
Sarah has never seen the file that keeps her from working for the US government and emigrating. The American lawyers working on her case have never seen it. I talked to one high-ranking US officer, who never worked with Sarah, but has detailed knowledge of her case. He said that in his view, the fact that she's been blacklisted is, quote, "A shameful situation and a gross miscarriage of justice." He believes the case against her was badly misinformed.
萨拉从未见过这份阻止她为美国政府工作和移民的档案。参与她案件的美国律师也没见过。我和一位美国高级军官聊过，他虽然没和萨拉一起工作过，但对她的案件有详细了解。他说在他看来，她被列入黑名单是——引述——“一种可耻的情况，是一次严重的司法不公”。他相信对她的指控是被严重误导的。
Sarah is still in touch with some of the American soldiers she worked with in the beginning. And she thinks about them a lot, how they're doing, how their families are doing.
萨拉仍然和一些早期合作过的美国士兵保持联系。她经常想起他们，他们过得怎么样，他们的家庭过得怎么样。
Because they are like, the persons who removed the dust from my real-- what you call it-- personality.
因为他们就像是那些掸掉我真实……你管它叫什么……真实个性上灰尘的人。
For the year and a half Sarah was working with the Americans, she felt recognized for who she really was for the first time in her adult life. It's a powerful feeling to be known like that and a terrible thing to lose.
萨拉为美国人工作的这一年半里，她第一次在成年生活中感到自己真实的一面得到了认可。被那样了解是一种强大的感觉，而失去它是件可怕的事。
The moment in our last Iraq show that made everyone remember Sarah happened when she was interpreting for us during an interview with a former Sons of Iraq fighter. He pulled a tissue from a box next to him to make a point.
在我们上一个伊拉克节目中，让每个人都记住萨拉的时刻发生在：她为我们翻译时，采访了一名前“伊拉克之子”战士。他从身边的盒子里抽出一张纸巾试图说明一个观点。
I'm sorry. He says the American forces use us like a tissue. I feel the same thing.
我很抱歉。他说美国军队把我们当纸巾用。我也感受到了同样的东西。
[CRYING]
[哭泣]
I'm sorry.
我很抱歉。
I wish I could tell you this story ends well. It doesn't. Sarah is stranded. She can't go back to being a housewife. She's got her kids to support. But jobs are scarce for a single woman whose employment experience is mostly a job she can't even talk about with a lot of Iraqis without putting her life at risk. She wants to be recognized. She just doesn't know when she's going to get the chance.
我真希望能告诉你们这个故事结局圆满。事实并非如此。萨拉被困住了。她没法再回去做主妇了。她还得抚养孩子。但对于一个单身女性来说，工作太难找了，她的工作经历大多是她甚至不能跟大多数伊拉克人提起的，否则会有生命危险。她想得到认可。她只是不知道什么时候才有机会。
[MUSIC - "I WANNA BE FREE" BY EVELYN HARLENE AND CASEY CLARK'S BAND]
[音乐 - 伊芙琳·哈琳和凯西·克拉克乐队的《我想自由》]
This week's program was produced by Robyn Semian with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, and Alissa Shipp. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Production help from Eric Mennel.
本周节目由罗宾·塞米安与亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、本·卡尔洪、简·费尔特斯、萨拉·科尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克和阿丽莎·希普共同制作。资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室主任。埃里克·门内尔提供了制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Torey Malatia, and editorial oversight by our other boss, Ira Glass. He told me this week that the secret to his casual, natural delivery on the radio? Comfy clothes.
《美国生活》由公共广播国际公司发行。节目受WBEZ管理层（我们的老板托里·马拉蒂亚）监管，编辑由我们的另一位老板艾拉·格拉斯监督。他这周告诉我，他在广播中那种随意、自然表达的秘诀是？穿着舒适的衣服。
Track suit. And pajamas.
运动服。还有睡衣。
More stories from This American Life next week, with Ira J. Glass.
下周请继续收听《美国生活》，艾拉·J·格拉斯会回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。公共广播国际公司。